- Benvenuto in Capire
l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico
di IBM Quantum Education.
Lo scopo di questa serie è fornirti
una solida comprensione dell'informazione e del calcolo quantistico, il che significa entrare
nei dettagli tecnici
dell'informazione quantistica e capire come funziona davvero il quantum
computing, cosa può fare e cosa non può fare.
Se non l'hai già fatto,
guarda il video panoramico di questa serie, ti consiglio di dargli un'occhiata.
In quel video troverai informazioni su quale tipo di preparazione di base
è consigliata per questa serie, oltre a una panoramica
degli argomenti che verranno trattati.
Assicurati anche di consultare
il libro di testo Qiskit, che tratta gli stessi
argomenti di questa serie video in forma scritta,
e include anche
componenti interattive e interfacce a hardware e software progettate per aiutarti a capire meglio
l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico. Troverai i link al video panoramico e al libro di testo Qiskit
nella descrizione.
Questa è la lezione uno della
prima unità della serie.
La prima unità tratta le basi
dell'informazione quantistica, e nella prima lezione di questa unità ci concentreremo su come
funziona l'informazione quantistica
per i sistemi singoli, il che significa che abbiamo
un solo sistema fisico o un dispositivo di qualche tipo che
memorizza informazioni quantistiche
e stiamo considerando come quel
singolo sistema o dispositivo funziona in isolamento.
Nella lezione successiva a questa, discuteremo come
l'informazione quantistica funziona quando abbiamo più sistemi, e questo ci permetterà
di descrivere concetti interessanti
e importanti come gli algoritmi quantistici che fanno uso di più qubit
e i protocolli quantistici
che coinvolgono più individui che elaborano informazioni quantistiche e le trasmettono avanti e
indietro tra loro.
Ma prima di entrare in quelle discussioni, ha senso iniziare con
l'impostazione comparativamente semplice di un singolo sistema in isolamento,
in parte perché è bene iniziare in modo semplice, ma anche perché come vedremo, la descrizione di come
funziona l'informazione quantistica
per i sistemi singoli in isolamento porta in modo molto naturale e logico alla descrizione di come
per i sistemi multipli.
Ecco una breve panoramica della lezione.
Inizieremo discutendo
l'informazione classica.
Ora, lo scopo di questa lezione non è spiegare come
funziona l'informazione classica, ma spiegare come
funziona l'informazione quantistica,
ma per spiegare come
funziona l'informazione quantistica, è molto utile iniziare
con l'informazione classica e usarla come un
punto di riferimento familiare
quando discutiamo l'informazione quantistica.
A livello matematico, l'informazione quantistica e quella classica hanno in realtà descrizioni abbastanza simili, con alcune differenze chiave, ovviamente.
In effetti, l'informazione quantistica
non è affatto separata dall'informazione classica.
È un'estensione
dell'informazione classica.
Il fatto è,
almeno a mio avviso, che non puoi davvero
capire l'informazione quantistica se non capisci
l'informazione classica,
quindi iniziare con l'informazione classica
ha senso.
Mi aspetto che questo
contenuto sia familiare ad alcuni spettatori, ma anche se lo conosci già, non ti consiglio di saltarlo.
Oltre a mettere in evidenza gli aspetti dell'informazione classica più rilevanti per
la comprensione dell'informazione quantistica, in questa parte introdurremo la
notazione di Dirac,
che è un modo standard
che useremo per descrivere vettori e
matrici in tutta la serie.
A quanto pare, la notazione di Dirac non è
specifica per l'informazione quantistica.
Può essere usata ugualmente bene nel contesto dell'informazione classica così come in molti altri contesti in cui compaiono vettori e matrici.
Passeremo poi all'informazione quantistica, e in particolare
discuteremo la rappresentazione degli stati quantistici come vettori,
un tipo semplice di misura chiamata misura nella base standard, e le operazioni unitarie, che descrivono i cambiamenti nel tempo discreto
nei sistemi quantistici.
Sempre nell'impostazione
dei sistemi singoli.
Prima di iniziare con la lezione stessa, sarà utile chiarire che esistono in realtà due descrizioni
dell'informazione quantistica: la descrizione semplificata, su cui ci
concentreremo in questa lezione
e in tutta questa prima unità, e la descrizione generale, che viene trattata in un'unità successiva, specificamente nella
terza unità della serie.
La descrizione semplificata,
fedele al suo nome, è più semplice ed è
tipicamente quella che si impara per prima.
Nella descrizione semplificata, come ho già suggerito, gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati da vettori e le operazioni sono rappresentate
da matrici unitarie.
Questa descrizione dell'informazione
quantistica è sufficiente per comprendere
la maggior parte degli algoritmi quantistici, per esempio,
quindi non è eccessivamente semplificata, è la cosa reale.
Tuttavia, come scopriremo
man mano che andiamo avanti, ha alcune limitazioni.
Per esempio, se vogliamo
modellare gli effetti del rumore sui sistemi quantistici, questa descrizione risulta insufficiente.
WEBVTT
La descrizione generale, d'altro canto, è più generale e in definitiva è più
potente in senso matematico.
In questa descrizione, gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati da una classe speciale di matrici
chiamate matrici densità,
e una classe più generale di
misure e operazioni può essere descritta, incluso
il rumore, per esempio.
È del tutto coerente con
la descrizione semplificata e in effetti puoi essenzialmente vedere
la descrizione semplificata
come un caso speciale della
descrizione generale, e include anche l'informazione classica come caso speciale.
È anche davvero molto
bella nel modo in cui tutto funziona, quindi ti incoraggio fortemente ad imparare questa descrizione generale
quando sarà il momento giusto, ma la descrizione semplificata è il punto di partenza più naturale, ed è quindi ciò che faremo.
Inizieremo parlando dell'informazione classica tenendo d'occhio gli aspetti
dell'informazione classica più rilevanti
per l'informazione quantistica
e il modo in cui viene
descritta matematicamente.
Immagina di avere un
sistema fisico o un dispositivo di qualche tipo che memorizza informazioni.
Daremo a questo sistema il nome X, ma questo nome non ha
nulla di importante.
Potremmo usare qualsiasi altro
nome se preferissimo, ma giusto per scegliere un nome,
chiameremo il sistema X.
Faremo un'assunzione su X, ovvero che esiste un
insieme finito di stati classici in cui X può possibilmente trovarsi
in un dato momento.
Qui, quando mi riferisco a uno stato classico, intendo una configurazione del sistema che può essere riconosciuta e
descritta senza ambiguità
senza alcuna incertezza o errore.
In realtà, questo è qualcosa a cui puoi pensare intuitivamente. A livello matematico, semplicemente definiamo l'
insieme degli stati classici,
lo scegliamo come vogliamo o nel modo che meglio
descrive il dispositivo con cui stiamo lavorando.
Diamo il nome sigma a
questo insieme di stati classici, e ancora una volta, sottolineo
che stiamo assumendo che sigma sia un insieme finito.
L'insieme degli stati classici
di questo sistema X non è infinitamente grande come
l'insieme di tutti i numeri naturali.
È finito, ed è semplicemente
un'assunzione che stiamo facendo.
Per esempio, potrebbe essere che X sia un bit, nel qual caso, l'insieme degli stati classici è l'insieme contenente due
elementi: zero e uno.
A volte ci riferiamo a questo
insieme come all'alfabeto binario.
Un altro esempio è che X è
un ordinario dado a sei facce, nel qual caso, gli stati classici sono i numeri da uno a sei.
Ovviamente, qui stiamo parlando
di un'astrazione.
Un dado a sei facce reale può
avere molti attributi diversi come la sua precisa
posizione, il suo orientamento,
la sua temperatura, e così via. Ma rispetto alle informazioni più tipicamente rilevanti quando parliamo di un dado a sei facce,
gli stati classici sono
i numeri da uno a sei indicati dal numero di punti sul lato del dado che è rivolto verso l'alto.
Se X è un interruttore su
un normale tipo di ventilatore elettrico che potresti avere in casa, allora forse gli stati classici
sono le impostazioni alto,
medio, basso e spento.
Questi sono solo esempi. Potremmo immaginare sistemi con insiemi di stati classici
diversi da questi, ma si spera che trasmettano l'idea
che questa nozione di stato classico è qualcosa che dovrebbe essere
familiare e può essere compresa in termini semplici e intuitivi.
Matematicamente parlando, l'insieme degli stati classici
è semplicemente un insieme finito, e naturalmente questo insieme deve
essere anche non vuoto.
Deve esserci almeno
uno stato classico in cui il sistema può trovarsi e devono esserci almeno due stati classici
se il sistema è utile per memorizzare informazioni.
Ora, in alcune situazioni, potremmo sapere che X si trova
in un particolare stato, ma in molte situazioni,
che si presentano nel contesto
dell'elaborazione delle informazioni, può esserci incertezza sullo stato classico di un
sistema in un determinato momento
così che ogni possibile stato classico abbia una certa probabilità associata.
Per esempio, se X è un bit, allora forse è il caso che X si trovi nello stato classico zero
con probabilità tre quarti e si trova nello stato uno
con probabilità un quarto.
Ci riferiremo a questo
come a uno stato probabilistico, e potremmo esprimere
questo stato probabilistico, come vedi qui,
semplicemente indicando quali
sono le probabilità per i diversi stati classici.
Un modo più conciso per esprimere
questo stato probabilistico è tramite un vettore, in particolare la rappresentazione
che vedi qui
è un vettore colonna, e questo vettore indica
quali sono le probabilità per i due possibili stati classici.
Per essere più specifici, la prima voce indica
qual è la probabilità che X si trovi nello stato zero, e la seconda voce ci dice qual è la probabilità
che il sistema si trovi nello stato uno. Questo è semplicemente il modo naturale per ordinare l'alfabeto binario,
o almeno, è il modo in cui
siamo abituati a farlo. Con zero prima e uno dopo.
D'ora in avanti, useremo
il termine vettore di probabilità per indicare un vettore come questo.
WEBVTT
In particolare, è un vettore le cui voci sono tutte
numeri reali non negativi e dove la somma delle
voci è uguale a uno,
quindi ha senso
pensare a queste voci come probabilità.
In questo esempio ci sono solo due voci perché ci sono solo due
stati classici del sistema di cui stiamo parlando,
ma in generale, ci possono
essere qualsiasi numero di voci, con la comprensione
che c'è una voce per ogni stato classico
di qualunque sistema di cui stiamo parlando.
Continueremo a
discutere l'informazione classica, i vettori di probabilità e
così via tra un momento, ma prima, sarà davvero utile
introdurre una notazione
per descrivere i vettori nota come notazione di Dirac.
In realtà, questa è solo la prima
parte della notazione di Dirac.
Ci sono un paio di altri
aspetti della notazione di Dirac che vedremo un po'
più avanti nella lezione.
Questa notazione sarà
molto centrale nel modo in cui descriviamo l'informazione quantistica, quindi è essenziale
capire come funziona,
ma fortunatamente è molto semplice e non ha davvero
nulla di specificamente collegato all'informazione quantistica,
quindi possiamo introdurla ora
nel contesto familiare dell'informazione classica.
Come prima, assumiamo di avere un insieme sigma di
stati classici di qualche sistema, e assumiamo
di avere un ordinamento
di questi stati classici, proprio come ci riferiamo a un
ordinamento dell'alfabeto binario
nell'esempio precedente. Un altro modo per dirlo
è che gli elementi di sigma sono posti in corrispondenza
con i numeri interi
da uno a quanti
elementi sono contenuti in sigma, che è ciò che questa notazione qui con le due barre intorno a sigma significa.
Questo è il numero di
elementi nell'insieme sigma.
Quindi c'è un primo stato,
un secondo stato, e così via.
L'ordinamento specifico o
la corrispondenza che scegliamo non sarà in realtà molto importante.
Ciò che è davvero importante è
che abbiamo un ordinamento e vi ci atteniamo.
Per molti insiemi di stati classici
che incontreremo, ci sarà un ordinamento standard proprio come abbiamo con
l'alfabeto binario,
e se non c'è un ordinamento standard, possiamo semplicemente sceglierne uno.
Ma qualunque esso sia, l'intesa è che vi ci atteniamo.
Ora, ecco la notazione
che viene introdotta.
Per qualsiasi scelta di uno stato classico a dal nostro insieme sigma, scriviamo questo qui, che si legge come ket a
per indicare il vettore colonna
che ha un uno nella voce corrispondente ad a e uno zero per tutte le altre voci.
Per esempio, se torniamo
all'alfabeto binario, che, come potresti aver intuito, è un esempio molto importante
a cui torneremo ancora e ancora. Allora ket zero e ket uno sono i vettori definiti qui.
Ket zero è il vettore
che ha un uno nella voce corrispondente allo stato classico zero, che è la prima voce,
e uno zero per tutte le altre voci, e in questo caso c'è
solo un'altra voce.
Allo stesso modo, ket uno è
questo vettore qui dove abbiamo un uno nella
voce corrispondente a uno,
che è la seconda voce, e uno zero per tutte le altre voci, che, ancora una volta, è solo una voce.
Ecco un altro esempio. In questo esempio, abbiamo un
insieme di stati classici sigma corrispondente ai quattro semi
in un mazzo standard di carte da gioco: fiori, quadri, cuori e picche.
In questo caso, non c'è davvero un
ordinamento universalmente concordato di questi semi.
Per molti giochi di carte, non c'è alcun ordinamento. Sono semplicemente quattro semi diversi e questo è tutto ciò che conta, e ci sono diversi giochi di carte che ordinano questi semi
in modi diversi, ma non importa davvero.
Possiamo semplicemente scegliere un
ordinamento come quello che vedi qui.
Questo è un ordinamento alfabetico secondo i nomi di questi quattro semi scritti in inglese,
Assumendo di aver scelto
questo particolare ordinamento, definiamo questi quattro vettori: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts e ket spades
come vedi qui, e questi vettori corrispondono
alla descrizione generale che vedi qui sopra.
Dato che abbiamo scelto
questo particolare ordinamento per questi quattro semi.
Possiamo fare la stessa cosa per qualsiasi insieme di stati classici
che scegliamo.
Tenendo a mente che un insieme di stati classici significa sempre un insieme finito e non vuoto.
I vettori di questa forma sono
chiamati vettori di base standard, ed è un fatto molto elementare sui vettori che ogni vettore può essere
espresso in modo unico
come combinazione lineare
di vettori di base standard.
Per esempio, tornando all'esempio di poco fa, il vettore di probabilità
che abbiamo visto può essere espresso
come vedi qui. È fondamentalmente solo un modo alternativo di esprimere i vettori
che sarà molto utile per diversi motivi in futuro.
WEBVTT
E con quella notazione ora a nostra disposizione, torniamo alla discussione
dell'informazione classica e degli stati probabilistici, in particolare.
E consideriamo cosa succede
quando misuriamo un sistema mentre si trova in qualche stato probabilistico.
Normalmente potremmo non
riferirci a una misura o all'atto di misurare
qualcosa in un contesto classico, ma il termine ha senso.
In sostanza, quando parliamo
di misurare il sistema X in questo contesto, intendiamo semplicemente che lo guardiamo e riconosciamo qualunque stato in cui si trovi.
Naturalmente, quando guardiamo il sistema, non vediamo uno stato probabilistico, vediamo uno stato classico,
e il particolare
stato classico che vediamo è uno che possiamo
immaginare venga scelto casualmente secondo le probabilità.
Ora, potresti obiettare su
basi filosofiche all'idea che lo stato classico che vediamo sia in qualche modo scelto a caso
nel momento in cui misuriamo o guardiamo il sistema: il sistema si trovava semplicemente in qualche particolare
stato classico per tutto il tempo
e abbiamo semplicemente
saputo qual era lo stato, ma ai fini del ragionamento sul
quadro matematico con cui lavoriamo,
va bene pensarla così e farlo ci permetterà di tracciare un parallelo con
l'informazione quantistica un po' più avanti.
Supponiamo che lo
stato classico che vediamo sia lo stato classico a, che potrebbe essere qualsiasi stato nel nostro insieme sigma.
Questo cambia lo stato probabilistico
di X in generale, almeno dal nostro punto di vista.
Le probabilità non hanno più
alcun significato perché sappiamo ora qual è
lo stato classico di X.
È a, e non c'è più
alcuna incertezza a riguardo.
Quindi diremmo ora
che la probabilità che il sistema si trovi nello stato a è uno.
Lo sappiamo perché l'abbiamo appena guardato e abbiamo visto che lo stato classico è a, quindi il nuovo stato probabilistico di X è uno
in cui la probabilità di
trovarsi nello stato classico a è uguale a uno.
E quello stato probabilistico è rappresentato dal
vettore di probabilità ket a.
Abbiamo un uno nella voce corrispondente allo stato classico a e uno zero in tutte le altre voci.
Per esempio, se consideriamo di nuovo
la situazione in cui X è un bit e abbiamo lo stesso
stato probabilistico di prima,
allora se misuriamo X, possiamo immaginare che avvenga una
transizione.
Con probabilità tre quarti, vediamo lo stato classico zero, e misurando, effettuiamo la transizione a ket zero
come nostro stato probabilistico,
e con probabilità un quarto, effettuiamo la transizione a ket uno.
Puoi pensarla come una transizione di conoscenza se preferisci, in contrapposizione a una vera e propria
transizione fisica,
ma ciò che è importante ai
fini di questa lezione è riconoscere come funziona la matematica.
È in realtà una cosa abbastanza banale, ma riconoscendo questa banalità, la descrizione analoga
per il contesto quantistico
potrebbe sembrare un po' meno misteriosa.
Una nota finale è che per un'altra persona che non ha visto quale
fosse lo stato classico di X quando l'abbiamo misurato,
lo stato probabilistico
naturalmente non cambierebbe come risultato del nostro averlo misurato.
Va bene. Individui diversi possono
avere conoscenze diverse di un particolare sistema e di conseguenza scegliere
stati probabilistici diversi
per rappresentare la loro
conoscenza di quel sistema.
Nell'ultima parte di questa discussione sull'informazione classica, parleremo delle operazioni classiche che possono essere eseguite su un sistema,
partendo dalle operazioni deterministiche.
Quando eseguiamo un'operazione su un sistema, il suo stato cambia generalmente di conseguenza, e in questo contesto, la parola deterministico significa
che il risultato dell'esecuzione
dell'operazione dipende interamente da qualunque
stato classico in cui si trovava il sistema
prima che l'operazione venisse eseguita.
In altre parole,
non c'è alcun elemento di caso quando viene eseguita un'operazione deterministica, quindi non è coinvolto alcun elemento casuale
o di incertezza.
In termini matematici, le operazioni deterministiche
sono descritte da funzioni.
Ogni funzione f della forma
che vedi qui, il che significa che sia l'input che l'output della funzione
corrispondono a elementi del
nostro insieme di stati classici sigma descrive un'operazione deterministica.
Lo stato classico a viene
trasformato nello stato f di a per ogni scelta di uno stato a.
Per ogni funzione f di questa forma, ci sarà sempre una matrice unica M che soddisfa questa condizione
che vedi qui,
ovvero che moltiplicando
M per il vettore ket a ci dà il vettore ket f di a,
e questo è vero per ogni
scelta di uno stato classico a.
Non è troppo difficile scrivere
una descrizione esplicita di M data qualunque funzione f
di questa forma che abbiamo scelto.
Avrà sempre esattamente
un uno in ogni colonna con tutte le altre voci uguali a zero.
Ed ecco la formula. La voce b, a di M è uguale a uno se b è uguale a f di a
e altrimenti è uguale a zero, e con questo intendiamo
che questa è la voce di M la cui riga corrisponde a b
e la cui colonna corrisponde ad a.
WEBVTT
Vedremo alcuni esempi tra un momento, e capiremo perché questa formula funziona.
Ora, potrebbe non essere chiaro perché vorremmo prendere una funzione ed esprimerla come una matrice in questo modo,
ma ha senso farlo. Una delle ragioni, e forse è la ragione principale, è che se abbiamo un sistema
in uno stato probabilistico
ed eseguiamo un'operazione deterministica
su quel sistema, allora lo stato probabilistico risultante può essere ottenuto
tramite la moltiplicazione matrice-vettore, ovvero, se il nostro sistema si trova
in uno stato probabilistico
rappresentato da
qualche vettore di probabilità v ed eseguiamo l'operazione deterministica descritta da M
su quel sistema, allora lo stato probabilistico risultante sarà dato da M moltiplicato per v.
Qui, a proposito, questa freccia con una piccola
barra come questa è semplicemente una notazione comune in matematica per indicare come una cosa viene mappata a
o trasformata in un'altra cosa. Potresti usare una freccia normale, ma questa è convenzionale
ed è riconoscibile e forse è un po' più specifica di una semplice freccia, che può avere molti significati diversi.
Ora guardiamo un esempio o una raccolta di esempi, in realtà.
Consideriamo cosa succede quando prendiamo il nostro insieme di stati classici sigma come ancora una volta l'alfabeto binario.
Non ci sono molte funzioni diverse della forma di cui stiamo discutendo quando questo è il nostro insieme di stati classici, e per essere più precisi, ci sono solo quattro
funzioni di questa forma.
Qui, queste quattro funzioni sono descritte dalle loro cosiddette tavole dei valori.
La prima tavola descrive
la prima funzione, che abbiamo chiamato f1.
Per ogni possibile input a sinistra, elenchiamo il corrispondente
output a destra, quindi f1 di zero è uguale a zero,
e f1 di uno è, ancora, uguale a zero, e questo significa che f1 è
la funzione costante zero.
Assume sempre il valore zero.
La seconda funzione f2
è la funzione identità.
L'output è sempre uguale all'input come puoi vedere dalla seconda tavola.
La terza funzione f3 è
descritta dalla terza tavola.
f3 di zero è uguale a uno, e f3 di uno è uguale a zero.
Questa funzione è meglio
nota come funzione NOT o negazione logica.
A volte la chiamiamo anche bit flip perché capovolge zero
in uno e uno in zero.
L'ultima funzione f4 è,
ancora, una funzione costante proprio come la prima, ma questa è la funzione costante uno
perché assume sempre il valore uno.
E queste sono le uniche quattro funzioni dall'alfabeto binario a se stesso.
Ecco le quattro matrici che corrispondono a queste quattro funzioni descritte dalla
formula di prima,
che puoi vedere qui, e se ne hai voglia, puoi mettere in pausa il video e verificarlo.
Ricorda solo che con le matrici, l'ordine degli indici è sempre righe prima, colonne dopo.
Quindi la voce b, a corrisponde
alla riga b e alla colonna a, ovvero la riga che corrisponde
allo stato classico b
e la colonna che corrisponde
allo stato classico a.
Quindi, per esempio, se guardiamo
la prima funzione, abbiamo che f1 di zero è uguale a zero
e di conseguenza, la
voce zero, zero di M1 è uguale a uno.
Bene, la voce uno, zero
che è qui è uguale a zero, e puoi fare la stessa cosa per il caso
in cui l'input è uguale a uno, e allo stesso modo per le
altre tre funzioni.
Puoi anche verificare che questa
formula di prima sia vera e puoi verificarla esaminando tutte le diverse
possibilità una per una.
E in effetti, se pensi al modo in cui
funziona la moltiplicazione di matrici, in realtà puoi semplicemente farlo a occhio.
Quando moltiplichi una matrice per un vettore di base standard come questo, puoi immaginare di prendere l'input
e di inserirlo nella
parte superiore di una delle matrici nella colonna che corrisponde
allo stato classico
all'interno del ket, e l'output che
ottieni è semplicemente quella colonna come vettore di probabilità.
Quindi per esempio, M3 moltiplicato per ket
zero ti dà zero, uno
come vettore di probabilità, che è ket uno.
M3 moltiplicato per ket
uno ti dà uno, zero, che è ket zero e così via.
Discuteremo le operazioni sugli
stati probabilistici ancora tra un momento, ma prima, introduciamo la seconda parte della notazione di Dirac.
Questo sarà utile
per parlare di operazioni e pensarle come grandi C, ed è anche uno strumento standard
che continueremo ad usare in futuro. L'impostazione è proprio come era prima.
Abbiamo qualunque insieme di stati classici sigma con cui stiamo lavorando e assumiamo di avere qualche modo di
ordinare quegli stati classici.
Scriviamo quindi questa cosa
che vedi qui dove questa volta la
barra angolata è a sinistra piuttosto che a destra per indicare il vettore riga che ha un uno
nella voce che
corrisponde ad a e uno zero per tutte le altre voci corrispondenti a tutti gli
altri stati classici.
Quindi la differenza tra
questa cosa e ket a è che questa è un vettore riga e
ket a è un vettore colonna,
WEBVTT
ma per il resto, i vettori
sono definiti in modo simile.
Leggiamo questo come bra a; non sono sicuro se si presume sia divertente, ma l'idea è che i nomi bra e ket
sono le due metà della parola bracket, e ne diremo di più
tra un momento.
Ma prima, diamo un'occhiata
a un esempio molto veloce.
Per l'alfabeto binario, abbiamo che bra zero è
questo vettore riga qui analogo a ket a,
tranne che è un vettore riga
invece di un vettore colonna e bra uno è questo vettore qui.
Ora in generale, se moltiplichiamo un vettore riga
per un vettore colonna, pensando a questi come matrici
che hanno solo
una riga o solo una colonna, otteniamo una matrice uno per uno, che possiamo pensare
come uno scalare.
Qui, a proposito, dovresti
pensare a queste stelle come che rappresentano numeri arbitrari.
In particolare, se
moltiplichiamo il vettore riga bra a per il vettore colonna ket b,
allora ci sono due cose che possono accadere.
Una è che a e b siano uguali, quindi sono lo stesso stato classico, nel qual caso, gli uni si allineano
e il prodotto sarà uguale a uno, oppure potrebbe essere il caso
che a e b siano diversi,
e quindi gli uni non si allineano e il prodotto è uguale a zero.
Un modo semplice per esprimere
queste osservazioni è così.
E solo per mantenere le cose ordinate, scriviamo questo prodotto così con solo una barra al centro e significa esattamente la stessa
cosa di questo qui.
E ora puoi vedere come
bra e ket si uniscono per formare un bracket, che è
anche chiamato prodotto interno,
e questa è una cosa
piuttosto importante su cui torneremo
nella lezione numero tre.
Moltiplicare un vettore colonna
per un vettore riga, d'altra parte, ci dà una matrice come puoi vedere qui.
Quindi per esempio, tornando ancora
una volta all'alfabeto binario, se moltiplichiamo ket zero per bra zero,
otteniamo questa matrice qui, e possiamo esaminare
le altre possibilità per vedere cosa succede.
Ket zero per bra uno ci dà
questa matrice qui dove l'uno si è ora spostato
in questa posizione.
Ket uno, bra zero appare così e questo è ket uno, bra uno.
Quello che vediamo accadere è che c'è un solo uno in una matrice che altrimenti è tutta zeri, e la posizione di quell'uno
è determinata da quali
stati classici scegliamo nel bra e nel ket.
Più precisamente, e
questo è vero in generale, per qualsiasi scelta di un insieme di stati classici, la matrice che otteniamo moltiplicando ket a per bra b
è la matrice con un uno nella voce a, b e uno zero per tutte le altre voci.
E ora che abbiamo sia la
prima che la seconda parte della notazione di Dirac, abbiamo uno strumento molto utile per collegare le operazioni con le matrici.
Quindi torniamo brevemente
alle operazioni deterministiche e ricordiamo che un po'
prima nella lezione,
è stato affermato che per ogni funzione f di
questa forma qui, abbiamo un'operazione deterministica che trasforma a in f di a
per ogni possibile stato classico a. E abbiamo detto che per
qualsiasi funzione di questo tipo, c'è sempre una matrice unica
M che agisce così
sugli stati di base standard.
Usando la notazione di Dirac, possiamo ora esprimere molto facilmente questa matrice come vedi qui,
e possiamo vedere come a volte
sia possibile lavorare con le matrici interamente
all'interno del quadro della notazione di Dirac
senza mai convertire esplicitamente
in vettori e matrici, intendendo rettangoli riempiti di numeri.
In questo caso, possiamo verificare che la
formula richiesta sia vera moltiplicando M per ket a.
Sostituiamo la nostra
espressione per M così e possiamo rimuovere le parentesi e unire il bra
b con un ket a così.
E questo perché la
moltiplicazione di matrici è lineare, in questo caso, nel primo argomento ed è associativa, quindi possiamo rimuovere le parentesi.
E ora, ricordando che abbiamo un a fisso di cui stiamo parlando mentre sommiamo su tutte le
possibili scelte di b,
questo bracket qui sarà
sempre uguale a zero quando b non è uguale ad a, quindi non ci sarà alcun
contributo alla somma,
e quando b è uguale ad a, il bracket sarà uguale a uno e quindi rimarremo con
questo singolo termine qui.
Questa è la formula che volevamo e quindi abbiamo un modo molto bello e semplice per esprimere una funzione come una matrice.
Oltre alle operazioni deterministiche, abbiamo anche operazioni che
introducono esse stesse casualità o incertezza sullo
stato classico di un sistema.
Usiamo il termine operazione probabilistica per indicare operazioni di questo tipo, e per essere precisi, quando diciamo operazione probabilistica,
intendiamo operazioni che
potrebbero introdurre casualità, quindi le operazioni deterministiche sono in realtà un caso speciale
delle operazioni probabilistiche
che semplicemente non introducono
alcuna casualità.
Ecco un semplice esempio dove
viene introdotta un po' di casualità.
Questa è un'operazione su un singolo bit. Il modo in cui funziona è che se lo stato classico
del bit è zero,
allora non succede nulla. Il bit rimane zero, ma se lo stato classico
del bit è uno, allora l'operazione capovolge il bit a zero
WEBVTT
con probabilità uguale a 1/2.
Non c'è un nome speciale
per questa operazione, almeno non che io sappia.
È solo un esempio, ma puoi immaginare di eseguire
questa operazione su un bit.
Proprio come le operazioni deterministiche, le operazioni probabilistiche possono
essere rappresentate da matrici e le loro azioni sugli stati probabilistici
sono date dalla moltiplicazione matrice-vettore proprio come prima.
Questa volta, non è necessariamente il caso che le matrici abbiano esattamente un uno in ogni colonna e zeri altrove.
Le operazioni probabilistiche sono
più generalmente rappresentate da matrici stocastiche.
Queste sono matrici le cui voci sono tutte
numeri reali non negativi e dove le voci in
ogni colonna sommano a uno.
Questo è equivalente a dire
che le matrici stocastiche sono matrici dove ogni colonna
forma un vettore di probabilità.
Ha senso quando si pensa all'
azione di una matrice su un vettore di base standard.
Consideri qualunque
stato classico si voglia e si immagina di inserire quello stato nella parte superiore della matrice nella colonna che corrisponde
a quello stato classico,
e quella colonna ti dice qual è
lo stato probabilistico che emerge come vettore di probabilità.
L'operazione probabilistica
nel nostro esempio, per esempio, è descritta da questa matrice qui.
Se eseguiamo questa operazione
sullo stato classico zero, allora lo stato probabilistico che otteniamo è dato dalla prima colonna,
che è, ancora, lo stato classico zero, o equivalentemente, lo stato probabilistico
dove zero si verifica con probabilità uno.
Se invece eseguiamo questa operazione sullo stato classico uno, effettivamente randomizziamo il bit e di conseguenza otteniamo
questo vettore di probabilità qui
dove la probabilità per
ciascuno dei possibili stati è uguale a 1/2.
In generale, se eseguiamo questa operazione su qualsiasi stato probabilistico, l'effetto è essenzialmente
solo una media ponderata tra le due colonne
perché è così che funziona la moltiplicazione matrice-vettore.
È lineare, quindi facciamo semplicemente la media dei due
possibili risultati di conseguenza.
Quando pensiamo alle operazioni probabilistiche
in questo modo, è naturale pensare
che possano introdurre o iniettare casualità.
Possiamo semplicemente leggere le colonne una per una e vedere la casualità
che introducono per ogni possibile stato classico.
Puoi anche pensare alle
operazioni probabilistiche in un modo leggermente diverso, ovvero che sono scelte casuali di operazioni deterministiche.
Per esempio, nel nostro esempio, possiamo pensare a questa operazione come equivalente a
lanciare una moneta equa
e o eseguire la
funzione costante zero o la funzione identità
ciascuna con probabilità 1/2,
e puoi vedere che è riflesso
qui da questa equazione.
Questo è sempre possibile per
qualsiasi operazione probabilistica, ed è abbastanza intuitivo.
Se hai fatto scelte casuali
come parte di qualche processo, potresti sempre immaginare di fare quelle scelte casuali in anticipo
e poi di codificare quelle
scelte in qualche raccolta di operazioni deterministiche.
È a volte molto utile pensare alle operazioni probabilistiche
in questo modo, e vedremo un esempio
di ciò più avanti in un paio di lezioni.
L'ultima cosa da dire
sull'informazione classica per questa lezione riguarda la composizione
delle operazioni probabilistiche, il che significa semplicemente eseguirle
una dopo l'altra.
Supponiamo di avere
qualche sistema chiamato X e M1 fino a Mn sono matrici stocastiche che rappresentano operazioni probabilistiche
su X.
Immagina prima di avere
un vettore di probabilità v, che rappresenta uno stato probabilistico
di X in un certo momento, e poi applichiamo prima
la prima operazione probabilistica a X, che è rappresentata dalla matrice M1, e poi applichiamo la seconda
operazione probabilistica,
che è rappresentata da M2.
Se lo facciamo, allora il
vettore di probabilità che otteniamo dopo aver applicato solo la prima
operazione è M1 per v,
e poi quando applichiamo
la seconda operazione, il vettore di probabilità risultante è M2 moltiplicato per qualunque vettore abbiamo ottenuto
dopo aver applicato M1. Quindi appare così.
Ora, la moltiplicazione di matrici
è un'operazione associativa, il che significa che non importa dove mettiamo queste parentesi.
Quindi potremmo altrettanto facilmente
mettere le parentesi così.
È molto semplice, ma è anche interessante perché rivela che possiamo
pensare all'operazione in cui prima applichiamo M1
e poi applichiamo M2
come una singola operazione.
In altre parole, l'
operazione probabilistica che otteniamo componendo la prima e
la seconda operazione probabilistica è rappresentata dal
prodotto di matrici, M2 per M1,
e questa è la stessa operazione indipendentemente da quale stato probabilistico
abbiamo iniziato.
Non abbiamo bisogno di sapere nulla del vettore di probabilità v per pensare o descrivere
questa operazione composta.
Nota che l'ordine
qui è M2 a sinistra e M1 a destra, che è perché la
matrice a destra, M1,
è quella che viene
moltiplicata per il vettore v, mentre M2 viene moltiplicata
per qualunque vettore otteniamo dopo aver moltiplicato per M1.
WEBVTT
Quindi dobbiamo sempre tenere presente che l'ordine in un certo
senso si inverte.
L'operazione eseguita
per prima è quella a destra e l'operazione che viene eseguita per ultima, o in questo caso, per seconda,
è quella a sinistra.
Se non ci fermiamo alla seconda operazione e le applichiamo tutte in
ordine partendo dalla prima e terminando con l'ultima, che è Mn,
allora la composizione di tutte
queste operazioni insieme è data da questo prodotto
che vedi qui,
e vedi che l'ordinamento
è ancora invertito per esattamente la stessa ragione di prima.
Quindi in breve, le composizioni
di operazioni probabilistiche sono rappresentate da prodotti
di matrici stocastiche che le rappresentano.
Tenendo presente che questo è
l'ordinamento delle matrici nel prodotto.
Otterrai sempre una matrice stocastica prendendo un prodotto di
matrici stocastiche così, e a volte esprimiamo questo fatto
dicendo che le matrici
stocastiche sono chiuse sotto la moltiplicazione, e il modo in cui
puoi pensarci è che non puoi uscire dall'
insieme delle matrici stocastiche
moltiplicandole perché l'insieme è chiuso.
Tornando all'
ordinamento delle matrici in questo prodotto, è importante notare che l'
ordinamento è davvero importante.
La moltiplicazione di matrici non è commutativa. Se cambi l'ordinamento delle
matrici nel prodotto, potresti cambiare il risultato,
e non dobbiamo guardare oltre le operazioni deterministiche
per vederlo.
Ecco un semplice esempio di
due matrici stocastiche, entrambe le quali rappresentano
operazioni deterministiche dove l'ordinamento è importante.
M1 rappresenta la funzione costante zero. Assumendo di immaginare che queste due operazioni siano su bit, proprio come nell'esempio precedente.
M2 rappresenta l'operazione NOT
o un bit flip.
Se esegui prima M1
e poi esegui M2, il risultato è questa matrice qui, che rappresenta la
funzione costante uno.
Se imposti un bit a zero
e poi lo capovolgi, è la stessa cosa che
impostare semplicemente quel bit a uno.
D'altra parte, se esegui prima M2
e poi esegui M1, questo è il risultato qui,
e ha senso perché se capovolgi un bit
e poi lo imposti a zero, è la stessa cosa che
semplicemente impostarlo a zero.
Non importava che tu lo avessi capovolto. Ovviamente, queste due
matrici non sono le stesse, e quindi abbiamo un esempio molto
semplice che rivela
che l'ordine è importante. Certo, questo non sorprende affatto.
Sappiamo tutti che l'ordine in cui
vengono eseguite le operazioni è importante, o almeno, può essere importante.
Per esempio, se accendi un
fiammifero e poi ci soffi sopra, il risultato è molto diverso
dal soffiare sul fiammifero prima
e poi accenderlo. A questo punto, abbiamo parlato abbastanza a lungo
dell'informazione classica e ora è finalmente tempo di
discutere l'informazione quantistica.
E quello che troveremo è che
matematicamente parlando, l'informazione quantistica funziona
in un modo molto simile all'informazione classica
con alcune differenze chiave.
La prima differenza chiave
è proprio all'inizio, come definiamo uno stato, in questo caso, uno stato quantistico di un sistema,
e c'è un senso in cui questa unica scelta su come
definiamo uno stato quantistico determina in larga misura come
funziona l'informazione quantistica.
Definiremo anche come
funzionano le misure e le operazioni, e nella prossima lezione, discuteremo come
l'informazione quantistica funziona non solo per i sistemi singoli
ma per i sistemi multipli,
ma queste cose in realtà
seguono abbastanza naturalmente una volta che la nozione di stato quantistico di un singolo sistema in
isolamento è stata stabilita.
Ecco la definizione. Uno stato quantistico di un sistema è rappresentato da un vettore colonna i cui indici sono posti
in corrispondenza con gli
stati classici di quel sistema.
Quindi stiamo assumendo qui che
il sistema di cui stiamo parlando abbia un qualche insieme di stati classici, proprio come quando abbiamo parlato
dell'informazione classica
e degli stati probabilistici. Le voci in un vettore di stato quantistico sono numeri complessi in contrapposizione al caso probabilistico
dove le voci sono
numeri reali non negativi.
E questa volta, la somma dei valori assoluti al
quadrato delle voci deve essere uguale a uno, in contrapposizione alla somma che è uguale a uno
come abbiamo nel caso probabilistico.
I numeri complessi che compaiono
in un vettore di stato quantistico sono a volte chiamati ampiezze e svolgono un ruolo
simile alle probabilità,
ma non sono probabilità e non hanno la
stessa interpretazione.
Ora, non posso darti una buona ragione per cui gli stati quantistici
dovrebbero essere definiti così, se non per dire che i
fisici hanno scoperto
che questa definizione
è fisicamente rilevante e ci permette di descrivere e modellare
i sistemi meccanici quantistici.
In altre parole, scegliamo questa definizione
perché funziona, non perché ci siano
ragioni particolari per cui gli stati quantistici dovrebbero
essere definiti così.
Per quanto riguarda la
matematica di questa nozione di stato quantistico, il primo passo verso la comprensione e il lavoro con essa è
richiamare questa definizione
della norma euclidea di un vettore, che puoi pensare geometricamente come la lunghezza di un vettore, proprio come penseresti alla lunghezza
di un vettore reale bidimensionale se lo disegnassi su un foglio
di carta come una freccia che parte dall'origine nel modo consueto.
WEBVTT
In particolare, se abbiamo un
vettore colonna v come questo, che assumiamo abbia
voci di numeri complessi, da alpha uno ad alpha n,
allora la norma euclidea di v è definita come vedi qui.
Questa è la notazione che
usiamo per la norma euclidea mettendo queste doppie barre intorno a qualunque vettore di cui stiamo parlando.
In questo caso è v, e il modo in cui la norma euclidea è definita è che è la radice quadrata della somma
dei valori assoluti al quadrato
delle voci del vettore.
Quindi un altro modo per definire cosa
è un vettore di stato quantistico è che un vettore di stato quantistico è un vettore colonna con
voci di numeri complessi
la cui norma euclidea è uguale a uno, il che significa che è un vettore unitario rispetto alla norma euclidea.
Questo perché la somma dei
valori assoluti al quadrato è uguale a uno se e solo se la norma euclidea
è uguale a uno.
La radice quadrata non cambia nulla quando la somma dei valori assoluti al quadrato è uguale a uno.
Quindi è questo un vettore di stato quantistico. È un vettore colonna con indici che corrispondono agli stati classici di un sistema
con voci di numeri complessi e norma euclidea uguale a uno.
Cosa significhi o cosa implichi o come dovremmo interpretare questa
nozione è un'altra questione e in un certo senso,
lo studio dell'informazione
e del calcolo quantistico è un'esplorazione di cosa
questa definizione implica, almeno, in termini di
elaborazione delle informazioni.
Questo è semplicemente il punto di partenza.
Come nota a margine, lasciami menzionare che ci sono
altre cosiddette norme oltre alla norma euclidea e questa notazione qui
con le doppie barre
intorno a un vettore non significa sempre
la norma euclidea.
In diversi contesti, questa notazione potrebbe fare riferimento
a una norma diversa.
Per esempio, la somma
dei valori assoluti senza quadrati o radice quadrata è una norma diversa,
spesso chiamata norma uno. Ci sono davvero molte
norme diverse.
A volte vedrai
questa notazione usata con un pedice dopo
il secondo set di barre che fornisce più informazioni su quale norma stiamo parlando.
E quando lo facciamo, è abbastanza tipico che il numero due come pedice
significhi la norma euclidea.
Ma in questa serie, ogni volta che abbiamo un
vettore colonna come questo, questa notazione con le doppie barre da sola
significa la norma euclidea.
Ecco alcuni esempi
di vettori di stato quantistico e questi particolari vettori di stato quantistico sono vettori di stato qubit,
il che significa che gli
stati classici del nostro sistema sono zero e uno.
La parola qubit è l'abbreviazione di quantum bit, che è in realtà solo un bit
che può trovarsi in uno stato quantistico.
I primi due esempi sono molto semplici. I vettori di base standard
ket zero e ket uno sono vettori di stato quantistico.
Sono entrambi vettori colonna, e gli indici corrispondono
agli stati classici zero e uno, e le voci di questi
vettori sono numeri complessi.
Per questi particolari vettori, le voci sono zero e uno, che sono numeri reali, e in effetti sono interi, ma sono anche numeri complessi
che hanno
parte immaginaria uguale a zero.
Ogni vettore ha una voce uguale a uno e una voce uguale a zero.
Quindi quando sommiamo i valori assoluti al
quadrato delle voci, otteniamo uno in entrambi i casi.
Quindi le condizioni
necessarie affinché questi vettori siano vettori di stato quantistico sono soddisfatte.
I prossimi due esempi sono stati qubit molto comunemente incontrati chiamati stato più e stato meno.
Sono indicati come
vedi qui sullo schermo, o con un ket più
o un ket meno così, e sono definiti come
puoi vedere qui.
Ancora una volta, le voci di questi
vettori sono numeri complessi. Questa volta, sono o più uno su radice quadrata di due o meno uno su radice quadrata di due,
e quando sommiamo i
valori assoluti al quadrato, otteniamo 1/2 più 1/2, che è uno.
A proposito, mettere un
segno più o meno all'interno di un ket così
potrebbe sembrare un po' strano perché questi non sono stati classici del nostro sistema,
ma questa notazione viene comunque usata, e torneremo su questo tra poco.
Ma per ora, in breve, possiamo usare la notazione di Dirac per mettere qualunque nome vogliamo per un vettore all'interno di un ket.
Il vettore non deve
essere un vettore di base standard quando usiamo la notazione di Dirac.
Ecco un esempio finale di stato qubit
per ora.
È un vettore di stato quantistico di un qubit che non ha un nome speciale, e non è particolarmente significativo.
Le voci di questo vettore sono uno più due per i
su tre e meno 2/3.
Questi sono numeri complessi, e se calcoli i
valori assoluti al quadrato di queste due voci, otterrai 5/9 per la prima
e 4/9 per la seconda. Quindi la somma del valore assoluto al quadrato è uguale a uno.
Ed ecco un ultimo esempio. Questa volta per un sistema
i cui stati classici sono i quattro semi delle carte.
Non so perché avremmo un sistema i cui stati classici
sono i quattro semi delle carte in uno stato quantistico, ma è possibile in linea di principio
ed è solo un esempio.
WEBVTT
Le voci corrispondenti
ai diversi semi sono 1/2 per fiori, meno
i su due per quadri,
zero per cuori perché non compare nella somma e uno su radice
quadrata di due per picche.
Ed ecco come appare
come vettore colonna, assumendo di aver ordinato
gli stati classici come abbiamo fatto prima,
che è l'ordine che
vedi qui.
Prendendo il valore assoluto al
quadrato di queste voci si ottiene un quarto per la prima, anche un quarto per la successiva.
Il valore assoluto al quadrato
di zero è uguale a zero, quindi quella voce non
contribuisce alla somma.
E infine, per l'ultima, otteniamo 1/2. Quindi la somma è uguale a uno come richiesto affinché questo vettore
sia un vettore di stato quantistico.
Ora, poco fa, abbiamo usato la notazione
ket più e ket meno per riferirci a due vettori di stato qubit che non sono vettori di base standard.
E vorrei tornare
brevemente su questo punto e spiegare come la notazione di Dirac viene usata per vettori arbitrari e non solo per vettori di base standard.
Come ho già menzionato, possiamo usare qualunque nome vogliamo
all'interno di un bra o ket per riferirci a un vettore.
I ket sono vettori colonna
e i bra sono vettori riga proprio come prima.
Come esempio, la lettera greca
psi è molto comunemente usata all'interno di un ket per riferirsi a qualche vettore arbitrario,
e qui la usiamo per
dare un nome al vettore di stato di prima che non
ha un nome speciale.
Quando lo facciamo, la lettera psi non
ha necessariamente alcun significato da sola.
È solo il nome di un vettore, ed è all'interno di un ket per aiutarci a chiarire
che è un vettore colonna.
Questo può essere un po'
confuso a volte, e c'è un potenziale di ambiguità se la lettera psi potesse essere associata
a uno stato classico di
qualche sistema per esempio, ma generalmente non
causa alcun problema, e non devi usare
la notazione di Dirac così
se non vuoi. Usare una lettera minuscola come
u, v, o w senza un ket è anche un buon modo per
indicare un vettore colonna
o più specificamente,
un vettore di stato quantistico.
Stai a te scegliere quale notazione
usare per esprimerti.
Devi solo assicurarti
che primo, il significato di ciò che stai
cercando di esprimere sia chiaro agli altri.
E secondo, che tu capisca ciò che
gli altri stanno cercando di esprimere anche quando le loro preferenze per la notazione non sono le stesse delle tue.
C'è una regola molto importante per usare la notazione di Dirac
per vettori arbitrari ed è che se hai un vettore colonna
che hai deciso di scrivere
come ket psi, per esempio, o potrebbe essere un nome diverso
all'interno di un ket, allora il vettore riga bra psi
si intende che sia
il trasposto coniugato del vettore ket psi.
E qui, questo è scritto come equazione dove questo dagger qui si riferisce al trasposto coniugato.
Quello che è specificamente è
il vettore riga che si ottiene, primo, trasponendo il vettore, il che significa che capovolgi
il vettore di lato e lo cambi da colonna a riga
senza cambiare effettivamente le voci. E secondo, prendendo il coniugato complesso
di ciascuna delle voci.
In realtà puoi eseguire
queste due operazioni, il trasposizione e il
coniugato complesso voce per voce in qualsiasi ordine, perché
queste due operazioni commutano.
Quindi per il vettore in questo esempio, dato che abbiamo deciso di
chiamare questo vettore ket psi, si intende che bra psi
significhi questo vettore qui
dove abbiamo traspostato il vettore trasformando ket zero e ket
uno in bra zero e bra uno, e abbiamo preso il coniugato complesso di ogni voce,
ecco perché uno più
due per i su tre diventa uno meno due
per i su tre qui.
Ecco come appaiono questi vettori quando sono scritti
esplicitamente come vettore colonna e vettore riga.
Nota, a proposito, che
questa regola è coerente con la notazione che usiamo quando abbiamo stati classici
all'interno del bra e del ket.
In quel caso, le voci sono
tutte zero tranne un uno, e quindi prendere il coniugato complesso non fa nulla in quel caso.
Abbiamo ora visto come gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati come vettori, ma non è chiaro a questo
punto quale sia il significato o le implicazioni
in termini di cosa
puoi fare con il sistema in uno stato quantistico o come puoi interagire con esso.
La prima cosa che dobbiamo fare per portare questi problemi a fuoco
è discutere le misure.
Intuitivamente parlando,
le misure forniscono un meccanismo per estrarre informazioni classiche
dai sistemi quantistici.
Quando guardiamo un sistema
quando si trova in uno stato quantistico, non vediamo uno stato quantistico proprio come non vediamo
gli stati probabilistici,
vediamo stati classici, e questa nozione di misura è ciò che fornisce l'interfaccia.
Se noi, come esseri umani, vogliamo sapere qualcosa su un sistema quantistico, dobbiamo misurarlo, e così facendo estrarremo informazioni classiche
su qualunque stato quantistico
in cui si trovava quel sistema.
Ci sono diverse
nozioni di misure. La differenza riguarda davvero la generalità, e inizieremo con quella più semplice e basilare,
che è tipicamente chiamata
misura nella base standard.
WEBVTT
Generalizzeremo questo
nelle lezioni successive. Parleremo delle cosiddette
misure proiettive nella lezione tre, e poi più avanti nella
terza unità della serie,
parleremo delle misure generali, chiamate anche misure a valore operatore positivo o POVM in breve.
Ma per ora, limiteremo la nostra attenzione alle misure nella base standard.
Quando viene eseguita una misura
su un sistema, ci sarà un qualche insieme
di possibili risultati di quella misura, che sono risultati classici,
e nel caso di una
misura nella base standard, quei possibili risultati sono
precisamente gli stati classici di qualunque sistema venga misurato.
Ciascuno di quegli stati classici sarà il risultato della misura con qualche probabilità, e quella probabilità è il valore assoluto al quadrato
della voce corrispondente
a quello stato classico di qualunque vettore di stato quantistico si trovasse il sistema immediatamente prima di essere misurato.
Sappiamo che il valore assoluto al quadrato di qualsiasi numero complesso è un numero reale non negativo, e sappiamo dalla definizione
dei vettori di stato quantistico
che la somma del valore assoluto al quadrato delle voci di un vettore di stato quantistico è uguale a uno.
Quindi questo ha senso. Ogni stato classico apparirà come il risultato della
misura con qualche probabilità e le probabilità sommano a uno.
Ecco alcuni esempi. Prima, supponiamo di avere un
qubit nello stato più.
Se misuriamo questo qubit rispetto a una
misura nella base standard, otteniamo zero o
uno come risultato.
La probabilità di ottenere zero è il valore assoluto al quadrato di uno su radice di due, che è 1/2, ed è la stessa
probabilità di ottenere uno.
Quindi se misuri uno stato più, otterrai un bit casuale uniforme.
Se il sistema si trova in uno stato
meno invece che in uno stato più, allora la misura funziona in
esattamente lo stesso modo.
Le probabilità sono, ancora, 1/2 per ogni possibile risultato.
L'unica differenza qui è che il segno più è diventato un segno meno, ma quando prendiamo il valore assoluto, nulla cambia.
Se misuriamo questo stato qubit, la probabilità di ottenere il risultato zero è il valore assoluto al quadrato di uno più due per i
su tre, che è 5/9,
e la probabilità di ottenere il risultato uno è il valore assoluto al quadrato
di meno 2/3, che è 4/9.
E infine, misurare
lo stato della base standard, ket zero dà il risultato
zero con certezza, e allo stesso modo, misurare lo stato ket uno
produce il risultato uno con certezza. Questo perché il valore assoluto al quadrato di uno è uno.
Simile a quello che avevamo nel
contesto probabilistico. Possiamo associare questi stati quantistici, ket zero e ket uno, al sistema che si trova
in quegli stati classici,
e questo esempio è coerente
con quella interpretazione.
Ora, proprio come avevamo nel
contesto probabilistico, se misuriamo un sistema quando
si trova in uno stato quantistico,
allora lo stato cambierà, in generale, come risultato dell'aver
eseguito quella misura.
In particolare, e ancora, questo è esattamente come avevamo
nel contesto probabilistico.
Se misuriamo un sistema e il risultato della misura
è lo stato classico a, allora il nuovo stato quantistico
del sistema diventa ket a.
Quindi per questo stato qui,
per esempio, vediamo lo stesso tipo
di comportamento che avevamo nel contesto probabilistico.
Se misuriamo allora con probabilità 5/9, otteniamo il risultato zero, nel qual caso, lo stato
effettua la transizione a ket zero,
e con probabilità
4/9, il risultato è uno, e lo stato effettua la transizione a ket uno.
A volte questo fenomeno è riferito come un collasso
dello stato quantistico, ed è il tipo di
cosa che tiene le persone
che studiano i fondamenti
della meccanica quantistica sveglie la notte.
Ma da una prospettiva puramente
matematica, è davvero abbastanza semplice
e molto simile a quello che abbiamo nel caso probabilistico.
La fonte di tensione qui, in un certo senso, riguarda la natura fondamentale degli stati quantistici e ciò che rappresentano
e come differiscono
dagli stati probabilistici. Ma a livello matematico, questo è forse quello che potresti aspettarti.
Nota, a proposito, che se
misurassi una seconda volta, otterresti esattamente
lo stesso risultato della prima misura.
Quindi c'è un limite su quanta
informazione classica può essere estratta da uno stato quantistico, e torneremo su questo punto presto
in un'altra lezione. Abbiamo parlato degli stati quantistici così come delle misure, specificamente le misure nella base standard,
che forniscono un modo per
estrarre informazioni classiche dagli stati quantistici.
L'argomento rimanente per
questa lezione sono le operazioni, in particolare le operazioni unitarie, che descrivono come gli stati quantistici dei sistemi
possono essere cambiati. Naturalmente, dato che i
vettori di stato quantistico sono diversi dai vettori di probabilità, ti aspetteresti che l'insieme delle operazioni consentite
sugli stati quantistici sia diverso da quello che abbiamo per
l'informazione classica, e in effetti, è così.
Mentre le operazioni sugli stati probabilistici sono rappresentate da matrici stocastiche, le operazioni sui vettori di stato quantistico
sono rappresentate da matrici unitarie.
Ecco la definizione delle matrici unitarie.
Una matrice quadrata U con
voci di numeri complessi è unitaria se soddisfa le uguaglianze
che vedi qui.
WEBVTT
Il dagger rappresenta
il trasposto coniugato, che abbiamo già visto per i vettori quando abbiamo parlato della notazione di Dirac
poco fa.
Qui stiamo eseguendo il
trasposto coniugato su una matrice piuttosto che su un vettore, ma è essenzialmente la stessa cosa.
Trasponiamo la matrice, il che significa semplicemente che
scambiamo righe e colonne, quindi la voce JK diventa la voce KJ,
e prendiamo anche il coniugato complesso
di ogni voce.
Inoltre, questa notazione qui
significa la matrice identità.
Queste due uguaglianze qui
sono in realtà equivalenti. Se ne hai una, allora
hai automaticamente l'altra.
Sono entrambe equivalenti a
dire che U è invertibile, e l'inversa è uguale
al trasposto coniugato.
Questo è vero solo per le matrici quadrate, tra l'altro. Se hai una matrice che non è quadrata, allora una di quelle due
uguaglianze potrebbe essere vera,
ma l'altra non sarà vera.
Ma qui, stiamo parlando
di matrici quadrate.
Quindi questa è la definizione standard
per le matrici unitarie, ed è comoda perché è facile verificare
se una matrice è unitaria.
Moltiplichi semplicemente la matrice per il suo trasposto coniugato su entrambi i lati e vedi se ottieni
la matrice identità.
C'è un modo equivalente per caratterizzare le matrici unitarie, ovvero che una
matrice quadrata è unitaria se e solo se non cambia mai la norma euclidea
di alcun vettore quando moltiplichi. Una matrice N per N U è unitaria se e solo se la
norma euclidea di U per v
è uguale alla norma euclidea di v per ogni vettore colonna n-dimensionale v con voci di numeri complessi.
E quindi, se v è
un vettore di stato quantistico, allora U per v è anche
un vettore di stato quantistico perché i vettori di stato quantistico
sono semplicemente i vettori con
norma euclidea uguale a uno.
In effetti, possiamo dire un po' di più, ovvero che le matrici unitarie sono precisamente le matrici che trasformano sempre i vettori di stato quantistico
in vettori di stato quantistico. Questa è una situazione simile a quella che abbiamo per le matrici stocastiche
e i vettori di probabilità.
Le matrici stocastiche
sono precisamente le matrici che trasformano sempre i vettori di probabilità in vettori di probabilità.
Quindi una volta che abbiamo deciso che le operazioni dovrebbero essere rappresentate da matrici, il che equivale a dire che le trasformazioni agiscono linearmente
sui vettori che rappresentano gli stati, queste scelte per gli insiemi
di operazioni consentite seguono naturalmente, almeno,
in senso matematico.
Ora vediamo alcuni esempi di operazioni unitarie su qubit.
Vedremo molti altri esempi
di operazioni unitarie nelle lezioni successive, comprese le operazioni unitarie nei sistemi
con più di due stati classici. Ma per ora, ci concentreremo solo
sulle operazioni unitarie su qubit.
Vedremo questi
particolari esempi presentarsi ancora e ancora, quindi vale sicuramente la pena imparare a conoscere queste operazioni.
La prima raccolta di esempi sono le cosiddette operazioni di Pauli.
Queste sono le operazioni che corrispondono alle matrici di Pauli, mostrate qui.
Sono tutte unitarie, e puoi verificarlo per ciascuna secondo la definizione di prima.
Queste particolari matrici
risultano essere uguali ai loro trasposti coniugati, il che significa che sono
tutte matrici Hermitiane.
Quindi verificare che siano
tutte unitarie, in questo caso, è una questione di elevare al quadrato ciascuna e vedere che il risultato
è la matrice identità.
I nomi che vedi per queste
matrici sono abbastanza standard, e vedrai anche
sigma x, sigma y e sigma z chiamate semplicemente X, Y e Z.
Tieni presente però che le
lettere maiuscole X, Y e Z sono anche comunemente usate per altri scopi, anche nel contesto dell'
informazione quantistica,
ma sono nomi molto comuni
per queste matrici.
L'operazione sigma x o X
è anche chiamata bit flip o operazione NOT, che abbiamo già visto
nel contesto classico.
E l'operazione sigma z o Z
è anche chiamata phase flip.
E qui puoi vedere l'
azione di queste operazioni sui vettori di base standard, che spiega un po'
da dove vengono questi nomi.
Ha certamente senso
riferirsi a sigma x come a un bit flip basandosi su questa azione qui.
Capovolge semplicemente il bit da
zero a uno o da uno a zero.
Ha anche senso
chiamare sigma z un phase flip basandosi su questa azione qui.
Ma se al momento non è del tutto chiaro, va bene.
Incontreremo questa
operazione ancora e ancora e il significato
di mettere un segno meno davanti al vettore di base ket uno e non ket zero
e perché si chiama phase flip sarà più chiaro in seguito.
Il prossimo esempio è
l'operazione Hadamard, che è rappresentata da
questa matrice qui, che è quasi sempre chiamata H.
Verificare che H sia unitaria è ancora una volta un
calcolo semplice, che se mi sposto, puoi vedere qui.
Simile alle matrici di Pauli, H è il proprio trasposto coniugato.
Quindi abbiamo questa uguaglianza qui, e quando eseguiamo la moltiplicazione, otteniamo la matrice identità come richiesto.
WEBVTT
Il terzo esempio è
in realtà un'intera classe di operazioni unitarie
note come operazioni di fase.
Queste sono operazioni
rappresentate da qualsiasi matrice che assume questa forma
che vedi qui dove theta è un numero reale qualsiasi.
Quindi questa voce qui sarà
sempre qualche numero complesso sul cerchio unitario.
Matrici come questa sono sempre unitarie, il che ti lascio verificare.
Questa volta, il trasposto coniugato non sarà uguale alla matrice originale a meno che questo numero qui non sia un uno o un meno uno,
nel qual caso, otteniamo o
la matrice identità o sigma z, che abbiamo
già incontrato.
In particolare, la trasposizione
non farà nulla a questa matrice, ma prendere il coniugato complesso di ogni voce cambia questa voce qui
in e alla meno i theta.
Queste due particolari operazioni qui sono esempi particolarmente importanti delle operazioni di fase.
Per la prima, prendiamo
theta uguale a pi su due, e otteniamo questa matrice qui.
Questa è comunemente chiamata
operazione S o S gate quando parliamo di circuit, di cui non discuteremo in questa lezione,
ma è un argomento importante
che sta arrivando presto.
La seconda è questa operazione. È un'operazione T o T gate.
E per questa, theta
è uguale a pi su quattro. E quindi quando calcoliamo l'esponenziale, otteniamo questo valore qui, che è uno più i su
la radice quadrata di due.
Ecco solo alcuni esempi veloci per vedere alcune di queste
operazioni in azione.
Ecco l'azione dell'
operazione Hadamard su ket zero e ket uno.
Se eseguiamo la
moltiplicazione matrice-vettore, vediamo che quello che otteniamo sono rispettivamente lo stato più e lo
stato meno.
Se eseguiamo l'operazione Hadamard sullo stato più e sullo
stato meno, d'altra parte, torniamo a ket zero e ket uno.
Quindi se sistemiamo un po' le cose, possiamo vedere l'azione più chiaramente.
L'operazione Hadamard
trasforma avanti e indietro tra lo stato zero e lo stato più e tra lo stato uno
e lo stato meno.
Riguardo a queste due equazioni qui, nota che questo ci dà un modo semplice per rilevare la differenza tra uno stato più e uno stato meno.
Come abbiamo visto prima nella lezione, se misuriamo uno stato più
e uno stato meno rispetto alla
misura nella base standard,
otteniamo un bit casuale uniforme in entrambi i casi, il che non ci aiuta a
rilevare la differenza.
Ma se eseguiamo un'operazione Hadamard
e poi misuriamo, vedremo zero se lo
stato originale era uno stato più
e uno se lo stato originale
era uno stato meno.
Quindi questi due stati sono davvero diversi, e possono essere discriminati
perfettamente con il metodo che ho appena descritto,
che è quello di eseguire prima
un'operazione Hadamard e poi misurare.
Tornando all'esempio di
uno stato qubit che abbiamo visto prima e che non è particolarmente speciale, possiamo vedere cosa fa l'operazione Hadamard allo stato
convertendo nelle forme
che vedi qui ed eseguendo la moltiplicazione.
Ed ecco il risultato
che possiamo riconvertire nella notazione di Dirac se vogliamo,
e questo è un modo per calcolare
questi tipi di azioni.
Ecco un altro esempio che illustra che non è sempre necessario
convertire esplicitamente in una forma matrice-vettore.
Puoi anche eseguire questi
calcoli direttamente usando la notazione di Dirac.
Questo esempio riguarda l'operazione T, ed eccola qui
per riferimento.
Questa operazione ha questa azione qui sugli stati di base standard.
E se vogliamo calcolare
l'azione dell'operazione T su uno stato più, per esempio, possiamo iniziare espandendo la
definizione dello stato più
e poi usare la linearità
per esprimere il risultato come vedi qui.
Ora possiamo semplicemente inserire
queste espressioni qui sopra, fare solo un po' di
semplificazione per il secondo termine, e otteniamo il risultato.
Se per qualsiasi ragione volessimo applicare un'operazione Hadamard
al risultato, possiamo fare una cosa simile.
Prima, sostituiamo l'espressione per T che agisce sullo stato più e usiamo la linearità come abbiamo fatto prima.
E ora, se sostituiamo le
espressioni che abbiamo già per l'operazione Hadamard
che agisce su ket zero e ket uno,
otteniamo questo. E ora, possiamo espandere lo stato più e lo stato meno per ottenere questa espressione qui,
che possiamo semplificare semplicemente sommando, ed ecco il risultato finale.
Non c'è nulla di particolarmente
speciale in questo esempio. È solo inteso a
illustrare questo modo alternativo ma equivalente di calcolare le azioni
di queste operazioni. Puoi usare qualunque
modo sia più conveniente nella situazione in questione.
Un punto finale sulle
operazioni unitarie è che le composizioni di operazioni unitarie sono rappresentate dalla moltiplicazione di matrici
proprio come nel contesto probabilistico, ovvero puoi calcolare l'azione di una sequenza di operazioni unitarie
semplicemente moltiplicando
le matrici insieme. E quello che otterrai è
una singola matrice unitaria che rappresenta l'azione combinata
WEBVTT
della sequenza di operazioni.
Proprio come avevamo per le matrici stocastiche, le matrici unitarie sono
chiuse sotto la moltiplicazione, quindi otterrai sempre una matrice unitaria
quando componi operazioni unitarie.
Devi assicurarti
di moltiplicare le matrici nell'ordine corretto.
Ma il modo in cui funziona è proprio come lo era per
le operazioni stocastiche dove la matrice per la
prima operazione che esegui
apparirà sempre sul lato destro
del prodotto di matrici, e l'ultima apparirà
sul lato sinistro.
Quindi proprio come prima, l'ordine è invertito nel senso che componi da destra a sinistra piuttosto che da sinistra a destra.
Ecco un esempio interessante che dà origine a un'operazione nota come operazione radice quadrata del NOT.
Supponiamo di applicare prima
un'operazione Hadamard seguita da un'operazione S, seguita da un'altra operazione Hadamard.
L'azione combinata di
queste tre operazioni è descritta da questo prodotto.
Ecco la prima operazione Hadamard, ecco l'operazione S e ecco la seconda operazione Hadamard.
Se eseguiamo la moltiplicazione di matrici, che non viene mostrata qui esplicitamente, ma puoi farlo
per te stesso se vuoi,
il risultato è questa matrice qui. È una matrice unitaria, e possiamo o verificarlo direttamente
o fidarci del fatto che le matrici unitarie sono
chiuse sotto la moltiplicazione.
Deve essere unitaria perché queste tre matrici sono unitarie come abbiamo già visto.
Non abbiamo alcun particolare
vettore di stato quantistico in mente qui.
Possiamo immaginare di eseguire
questa sequenza di operazioni su qualsiasi vettore di stato quantistico, e questa matrice descrive l'azione.
Il motivo per cui questa operazione combinata, ovvero quella descritta
da questa matrice qui, è chiamata operazione radice quadrata del NOT,
è che eseguendola
due volte, otteniamo un'operazione NOT, o in altre parole, un'
operazione sigma x o X.
Eseguire l'operazione
due volte è rappresentato dall'elevare al quadrato la matrice, ovvero
moltiplicarla per se stessa.
E se lo fai, vedrai che il risultato
è la matrice Pauli x.
E questo è un po' peculiare, e ti dà solo un accenno che puoi fare alcune cose interessanti con l'informazione quantistica che non puoi fare con
l'informazione classica.
Non c'è nessuna operazione classica, ovvero una rappresentata
da una matrice stocastica, che ci dia un'operazione NOT
se la eseguiamo due volte.
Quindi è un bel esempio che rivela che le operazioni quantistiche
si comportano in modo molto diverso dalle operazioni classiche.
E con questo, è tutto per la lezione uno. In questa lezione, abbiamo discusso come l'informazione quantistica funziona per i sistemi singoli in isolamento,
e nella prossima lezione, parleremo di come
l'informazione quantistica funziona per i sistemi multipli.
Grazie per aver guardato. Se hai domande, sentiti libero di lasciarle nei
commenti qui sotto.